- Before we go everybody,
I have one last story to
put a smile on your face.
This is What I'm Liking.
(bouncy music)
(audience clapping)
The mullet, America's
most important hairstyle.
Throughout history, it's been worn
by such luminaries as
Jean-Claude Van Damme.
(audience laughing)
He'll kick your butt.
Joe Dirt.
(audience laughing)
Go on a date with that dude.
That one dude you went
to high school with.
That's our script supervisor
Derek back in the day.
(laughing)
And of course my good
friend, Mr. Blake Shelton
(audience cheering and clapping)
Freaking just awesome,
and it's curly as well.
The curl is the best part, Blake.
Ah, now it's time to add
one more name to that list.
11 year old Allan,
who's the 2021 Kids Winner
at the USA Mullet Championship.
He so good.
(audience clapping)
Allan first grew his
luscious locks in quarantine.
His win comes with a cash prize.
(mimicking trumpet)
But what's really cool,
is he donated all of it
to an important cause.
Let's say hi to Allan
and his mama, Leslie.
Hi, you all!
(audience clapping)
- Hi.
- Hello.
- Oh, my God! I love your hair.
You win man.
It's so, you've literally did.
Um, but Allan give the
people what they want.
Show us your amazing hair.
Can you turn around?
Can you see, can you let us
see the party in the back?
Yeah!
(audience clapping)
I feel like Blake Shelton
would be proud of you,
that's all I'm saying.
Um, well, Leslie, whose idea was it
to grow his hair out?
- Well, back in shut down 2020
when the world closed
down because of COVID,
we were trying to think of creative ways
to keep the kids entertained
and having a good time,
and so we just started doing
crazy things with our hair.
So my daughter dyed her hair teal,
I dyed mine red,
my husband had an awful mustache,
and Allan he did a mullet.
- I love it.
(audience clapping)
Oh my God, the reveal with the hat
and the Beyoncé wind machine,
all of it was so great.
Um, so Allan, there was
a cash prize of $2,500
and you donated all of it, right?
- Yes ma'am.
- Okay, so why'd you donate it?
I mean, that's amazing.
But why did you do it and
where did you donate it?
- Well, I donated it to
foster care Project Zero
and Together We Foster
because I am been in foster care.
So, I just want to give back to the people
who gave me this wonderful mom.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- I'm fine.
Everything is fine.
- [Leslie] Yeah, we didn't that one.
- Oh my.
- He didn't said that in the rehearsal.
- Oh my gosh, Allan, you just broke me
in like the most amazing tiny
little pieces ever just now.
Um, so do you have any
plans to cut your hair?
Because it's kind of cool.
You've got like a cool
country mullet going on,
but it's kind of Euro as well.
It's kind of Euro rock and
roll punk, I'm just saying.
- Well, nobody's gonna touch my hair.
(laughing)
- I love it!
(laughs)
Thank you, Allan.
We love you,
and that was such a beautiful thing
you did to donate the money.
I'm liking your post right
now, and that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show,
also loves your luscious mane.
All right?
So in recognition,
they'll be using their
FriXion erasable pen
to write you a cheque for a 1,000 dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Oh my God!
- Yes!
(clapping)
You can use that for yourself,
or you can donate it.
You can do whatever,
but since you donated,
why don't you spend a
little something on yourself
and have fun, all right?
- Okay
- You can take, you can
take mama on a date.
That'd be, that'd be cool.
All right, well thank you guys so much.
(audience clapping)